namoosh was picked up at this bus
terminal in marseille on friday he had
arrived from brussels when customs
officials detained him
he was in possession of a revolver a
kalashnikov rifle and a gopro video
camera
all things which were used in the
murders in brussels
prosecutors also said the suspect had a
video file in which a male voice takes
credit for the brussels killings
last week an attacker entered the jewish
museum in brussels and shot and killed
three people a closed circuit television
camera captured the moment of the attack
namosh was already known to authorities
he's believed to have come into contact
with radical islamists in prison before
going to syria
he stayed more than a year in syria he
appears to have joined a group
senior members of brussels jewish
community say they're afraid namoosh's
arrest will not spell the end of
anti-semitic attacks
of course we feel relieved by the jewish
community is relief but i would say
partially since we all know that
unfortunately this guy is not alone
hundreds of radicals have left europe
nearly 800 from france alone to join the
syrian civil war
fears are mounting but many will use
training they acquire there to carry out
a tax when they return home